Film Courage: Your bio says you moved from Chile to
the San Francisco Bay Area in 1995?  How do you
think spending a good chunk of the
beginning of your life in an area where
a lot of artists were silenced affected
your need to want to tell stories? Yvan Iturriaga, Filmmaker (The North Pole TV Show): Yeah
growing up in Latin America I grew up in like
eight different countries in Latin
America we moved around a lot and I was
always surrounded by people who were
exiled from Chile who... people
whose stories were silenced, it was
dangerous to tell your truth and I've
realized more and more as I grow
older that that's definitely my main
motivation is to tell stories that don't
fit into the mainstream, that challenged
the mainstream and they are from voices
who are usually pushed back or silenced
and yeah I didn't realize at the time
but a lot of being an exile and fighting
against the regime that's trying to
silence you storytelling is kind of
therapy storytelling is yeah means of
survival and it means of organizing and
so for me filmmaking is that I I grab
onto that and I every project I work on
it has to address the society we live in
has to address people that are at the
margins and it has to be used as a tool
to change things I know you've done
documentaries on different journalists I
think and then Pedro Guerrero the
photographer so in an age where now
everyone can tell a story and it's
almost encouraged and everybody's
supposed to be a quote-unquote
influencer
and whatever their little niches how is
that for you knowing you grew up around
a lot of people that were fearful of
saying anything how does that work in
your mind huh you know it's interesting
because my family is still nervous about
sharing their story
you know like for for my parents is even
hard to say what they went through and
so sometimes even now in an interview
you know I have this is weird like
subconscious barriers sometimes to be
fully open about what you've been
through
and so in filmmaking it and when you
interview people I really understand
that when you're interviewing somebody
and you're doing documentaries you're
almost like having a very vulnerable
moment and you have to really appreciate
that value that and respect that and the
same thing in fiction you know our
project were the North Pole and
different parties I've worked on you
you're telling real people stories the
North Pole is about real people that we
know in our community so you have to
really acknowledge that that could be
something very vulnerable that could be
something very intimate and that you're
exposing it to the world and that's your
responsibility to do it right and I
think that that relationship to truth
into personal history is something that
I am very careful bound respectful about
on a passenger question does yeah
absolutely this is a little more of a
lighter question a movie that you were
embarrassed to admit that you loved The
Princess Bride
yeah how did you find it out one of our
interns nice yeah no it's a it's funny
I'm uh
I rarely allow myself to watch something
just for fun but I think it was really
fun and well-made and memorable I mean
you go on a--throw yeah you know even
watching that movie before I knew
English fully like I remembered him and
he was like stuck with me and if a movie
can do that I think it's a big success
but as a filmmaker you say you don't see
that many films I don't why is that I
think two hours of your life is a long
time to spend doing anything and so I
don't consume film
and that way or TV or streaming I I like
playing soccer I like hanging out I like
doing other forms of art I like spending
time with real people and so I actually
have a lot of friends I trust their
taste and I know my taste and once I
hear like a few solid recommendations
about something I'll go and watch it
there's obviously certain things that I
have my own
like you know anything that comes out of
the bay I'm gonna watch regardless
anything that has controversy and people
like oh and then deals with social
justice even if most people hate it I'm
gonna watch it because I have to have an
opinion but most things that like oh
that was cool
I'm not gonna watch it like why so I'm
I'm pretty picky I guess and has to move
me you know it has to inspire me and so
if I'm gonna learn something I
definitely want to watch it and if or if
it's a commentary on something I care
about and now I want to have a discourse
with you know so why the North Pole what
why you you launched crowdfunding
campaign or - this is your second series
second season for the North Pole okay I
definitely think it fulfills all my
requirements to watch it it's gonna make
you think it definitely has a stance and
I feel like almost anybody can learn
something from it and it's based on real
people's experience and in our town in
Oakland but it's very relatable to a lot
of cities in this country I mean it's
kind of like a symbol of an experience
that's happening a lot in the country
yeah did you see something similar
happen growing up in Chile or whatever
area you grew up different years I know
gentrification wasn't a thing I grew up
with in Latin America but definitely you
know the horror gentrification is a
class issue that's definitely at the
core of my experience in Latin America
you know and then end of the world and
calling it what it is you know it's a
class struggle is something that nobody
says in the show but in my ideology
that's what's happening it's
gentrification is a green issue and rich
people in the Bay San Francisco being in
one of the richest cities in the world
and how that starts affecting the
surrounding areas and folks who aren't
have access to that capital that
experience is worldwide and then you
know they're our second season is is
about an immigrant it's about an
undocumented immigrant
and that story is based on a friend of
mine since high school who actually used
to lie to us he said he was Puerto Rican
and I took him like ten years to reveal
that he was actually Salvadoran
and so you know and I've seen him go
through his life with with struggles who
at the time I didn't understand why but
you know he wanted to be a fireman he
wanted to be a airline pilot and he was
never able to achieve that you know I
was on the first plane he flew small
little Cessna and it was scary but that
experience is similar to in my childhood
I was surrounded by exhales which are in
essence people are forced to emigrate
and yeah those those experiences of
feeling like you don't belong and you're
not accepted and you have to hide who
you are it's definitely part of like my
family's history in my community and a
close friend of mine Hawai I we use as
an inspiration it's a loose inspiration
but reduces as an inspiration for Benny
the main character whose idea was it to
begin writing the show it was initially
me Josh Healy and Darren Coulson got
together I mean me and Josh had been
working on a handful of other projects
that were kind of one-offs dealing with
you know we had one with boots Riley
about a climate justice March that
occurred we did one for that we did
another one dealing with immigration so
they were all kind of one-off pieces you
know we didn't want to against off
fracking I tagged and Jerry Brown in a
nice way and but we kept talking about
let's do something bigger you know let's
get into characters let's tell a longer
story and so we all had that motivation
so the three of us got together went on
a little mini retreat and just started
brainstorming and coming up with
characters and ideas and planning out
what would be this world and that's
where I'm at him would you write on your
own and then bring it back to the two
other gentlemen and say no the first
season was that three of us
brainstorming together a lot Josh was
definitely the the lead writer
and that meant that we would all
brainstorm and him he would go and chop
things down and I would tell him he was
wrong and then he would tell me
otherwise and that's you know that's how
he created the show on different
characters and the second season Darin
became just to produce certainly bird on
the leads to of the leads
Dante Clarke and Rayna Maia and then
ever became his four-person room and
same thing Josh being the showrunner and
then before our let's just you know
getting creative together
you